Okay.
I think I should begin.
So we're,
uh,
at the point of the course now where we're talking about the capital asset
pricing model and the economists
understanding of risk aversion and its consequence for the financial sector.
So much of what economists,
uh,
no,
it was already known,
you know,
two businessmen because it's common sense and even to literary writers like
Shakespeare who was himself quite a successful businessman.
So you might remember that Shakespeare,
uh,
already had the idea of diversification.
Okay.
In the merchant of Venice,
Antonio says,
uh,
each boat on a different ocean,
you said it a bit more poetically than that,
but you know,
each sale on a different Argosy or something,
I forgot what it was,
but anyway,
each boat in a different ocean.
So it wasn't very worried because it was diversified and he also had the idea of
a risk and return,
you know,
nothing ventured,
nothing gained,
nothing ventured.
So ventured means risk,
nothing gained.
So another way of saying this,
diversification is a,
don't put all your eggs in one basket.
Okay.
So how could a,
so what of economists done that wasn't already known to every business person
and every clever literary writer will economists have quantified this and turn
this into,
uh,
a usable practical piece of advice.
So the diversification CRM and cap m,
so I should have moved cap and I should have called this Shakespeare
and this cap him.
Cap m becomes the mutual fund theorem.
So the mutual fund ferrum has very practical advice.
It says if you're investing in the stock market,
don't try to pick out individual stocks.
Hold every stock in proportion.
So its value in the whole economy.
If you want to be more venturesome,
don't pick riskier stocks.
Just simply leave less money in the bank.
So divide all your money between the index and the bank.
It says,
hold all your money in stocks in the same proportion,
everyone else's holding them hold the market.
In other words,
holding an index like the s and p 500 of all the stocks in proportion to how big
they are.
And if you want to get more venturesome,
you know,
if you're,
if you're cautious,
put some of your money in the,
in the index and some of it in the bank.
If you want to be more venturesome,
take some money out of the bank and put it into the stocks.
But in the index,
if you want to be even more vendors than,
than that,
borrow the money to put the money into the stock market.
That's called leverage.
Okay?
But you should,
according to this theory,
not try to pick stocks.
So if you're interested in risk,
you shouldn't pick high technology startup companies.
You should pick the same mixture of,
uh,
you know,
blue chip companies like General Electric and these startup companies that
everybody else is choosing.
So that's what it means.
Diversify,
hold a little bit of everything in the same proportion as everyone else.
So it's much more precise,
much more surprising.
Uh,
then Shakespeare's advice.
Okay?
Then the,
then the,
uh,
you know,
then the second thing,
risk and reward,
it says that the price of a security,
so we'll call it a pie,
Jay say,
which we used to think of as the expectation.
Of course you need the probabilities of the payoff of the security,
Jay.
Okay.
Discounted.
That's what we would have thought the price was.
So this is called the covariance pricing theorem.
Cool.
Okay.
The shocking thing is it's not the expectation discounted,
which is what we thought it was before.
Okay.
We know that you have to adjust for risk somehow,
which we haven't taken into account before.
But what's so shocking is you might've thought you'd subtract maybe something
times the variance of the return of acid Jay,
but that's not going to be the case.
It's going to be surprisingly subtracting something times the covariance with
the market of acid Jay.
Okay.
So you penalize the price of a stock should go lower if it gets riskier.
It's risk is not defined by what it's variances,
but,
but by what?
It's covariances with the market.
So I want to develop these two ideas,
uh,
in this lecture,
spend the whole lecture on just developing these two ideas,
which was a mile for modern mathematical version of what Shakespeare already
knew 400 years ago,
but made much more concrete,
much more precise with uh,
um,
the mathematics holy behind them.
So,
so what have we got here?
We imagine a world,
the situation,
I'm going to describe as the one we had last time where we know that there are
different things that can happen.
These are the states with different probabilities.
So there's states,
yeah,
s equals one to big s and each of them have probabilities with probabilities.
Yeah.
Mama s
of course,
the,
some of the gamma asked equals one.
So everybody knows the probabilities of the states and then they know what the
payoff is and the different assets.
So here's a one,
here's a two,
here's a j say and they know what the payoffs are going to be.
A one in state won 81 in state to a one state s eight two and state one eight
two.
I'm state S A J and state one ADJ in state s.
So given these probabilities and given the payoffs,
you can compute the expectation of each thing.
You can compute the expectation of a j.
Say it's just the summation for mass equals one to s of gamma s a j s.
Okay.
You can also compute the variance.
So I'll,
I'll write that sometimes is a bar j you can compute the variance of a j,
which is the summation s equals one to ask.
Remember of gamma s a j s minus a bar and j squared.
Okay.
And you could also compute the covariance of any to a j and a k
as summation,
gamma s a j s minus a Bar j times this is s equals one to s of a k s minus a
four k.
Okay,
so those three numbers,
the expectation,
the variance and the covariance between any pairs,
those are numbers that anybody could compute.
Knowing the payoffs are the assets and knowing the probabilities and what the
theory is going to say.
The capital asset pricing model.
That model is going to explain how the prices of all the acids depend on their
expectation,
their variances in their covariances under the assumption that people have
quadratic utilities or more generally assume,
uh,
okay.
Assume people
only care about the mean.
That's the expectation and variance.
Okay.
A final consumption.
Okay,
so we wrote that last time we said if you had quadratic utility for consumption
in every state,
you could summarize these foul,
you know,
there could be millions of states and thousands of securities.
You add them all together and what you hold,
it depends.
It only depends on the end about what the expectation and the variance of your
final portfolio is.
You like expectation and you hate variance.
So under that hypothesis,
we're going to have a very concrete interpretation of what Shakespeare was
talking about from the beginning,
which is gonna allow us to quantify what you should do,
how people in the market are doing.
We'll be able to answer series of questions.
Okay.
And then we'll be able to test the theory too.
So now the theory,
uh,
I'm about to explain was developed in 1950 began in 1950 when coupons,
who's a professor at the Coles Foundation,
the director of the Coles Foundation was in Chicago.
I told you the Coles Foundation was started by Alfred Cole's who'd been a Yale
undergraduate and his family owned the Chicago Tribune and a bunch of other
newspapers and he ran a macro economic forecasting company in 1929 right after
the crash.
He was embarrassed to realize that,
uh,
he had predicted that everything was going to be fine and he sent around
questionnaires and read everybody else's is competitors,
you know,
newspapers and realize they've been predicting everything was going to be fine
too,
except for one guy,
you know,
Jones,
Dow,
the Dow Jones Guy,
except for that he,
everybody had been making the same,
you know,
rosy predictions.
And so he decided the whole subject of economic forecasting,
in fact,
economics altogether was a fraud and he wanted to,
to put money in encouraging the use of mathematics and economics instead of the
touchy feely.
Uh,
you know,
more qualitative analysis that was the norm at the time.
So he took,
he went to see Irving Fisher,
who is the great Yale economist and said,
what should I do with all the money?
Where should I put this institute and who should I invite to the institute?
So Fisher and he set up the whole thing and it started in Colorado Springs
because Fisher believed in fresh air and he wrote a lot of books about fresh air
and how it staved off tuberculosis and things like that.
And no one wanted to go to Colorado Springs.
So they moved it to Chicago where the family was originally from the cold's
family.
And I'm the director then in the 50s was sown in coupons and coupons,
had this idea of trying to examine risks by making people with quadratic
utilities.
And he said,
okay,
student Markowitz,
why don't you try to develop a theory?
And Marco,
it's wrote,
began the theory of the capital asset pricing model.
Now the theory,
just to get a little ahead of the story,
Mark Woods went quite a ways,
won a Nobel prize many years later for what he did,
but didn't quite get to the end.
And while he was working on it,
uh,
coupons didn't want to be director anymore of coals.
And he invited Tobin,
the Great Yale economist to come and be a director of coals and Tova and got
there.
And the coal,
the people at the University of Chicago said to Tobin,
what?
We're glad you're coming,
you'll be right next to us.
But you know,
don't try and get us mixed up with all those mathematical people at the Coles
Foundation.
They're all crazy.
We would like to keep the mathematics,
you know that high tech mathematics out of our department.
That's just colds.
Crazy idea.
So Tobin refuse the job.
Came back to Yale and Marco,
it's was so angry and not Mark Woods,
uh,
coupons.
His advisor was so angry that he went to Kohl's and said,
they're not treating right at the University of Chicago.
Let's move the entire Coles foundation to Yale.
So in 1955,
they moved to,
to Yale.
But in these conversations,
Tobin had with coupons and the colts foundation,
he got to know what Markowitz was doing.
And so he added the final,
uh,
crowning achievement to the mutual fund theorem to the Markowitz,
set up.
And then he subsequently won the Nobel prize for that.
In fact,
the New York Times said in his,
uh,
right after and get in his,
it's description of what he won the Nobel Prize for the New York Times,
said James Stone on the Nobel Prize for showing that you shouldn't put all your
eggs in one basket.
So,
so anyway,
I will.
So that's the theory that I have to explain now that it's a little bit less
trivial than just saying don't put all your eggs in one basket.
So the idea is that you like expectation,
you hate variance.
So the first thing we're going to do is noticed that covariance,
I mean,
sorry,
standard deviation is defined as the square root of variance.
And so to say that you don't like variants means you don't like standard
deviation or the same thing,
but you're going to see it makes the diagrams much prettier.
So if we had a portfolio that you could choose among some combination of putting
your money in the A's,
that's okay.
Putting your money in the A's,
you get some expectation and some standard deviation for your total portfolio
and people like more expectation and like less standard deviation.
So the indifference curves are going in that direction,
unlike the usual picture.
That was the first step.
Now,
the first thing we noticed last time we made a very,
and this was uh,
three weeks ago or so,
we made an extremely important observation.
We said,
what is the covariance of part of your money in x and the variance of part of
your money in x and part and the rest of your money?
Let's say you have $1,
so TNX and one minus t and y for example,
half an ax and half.
And why?
Well,
that is by definition the same as the covariance of this portfolio with itself.
And now we know this from this fear,
from,
from this definition of covariance that if you look at the covariance of Jay
with Kay,
so fixing Kay,
this is just linear.
It's just the expected.
Did you know this is a constant multiplying the differences from Jay and it's
expectation.
So,
so this is a linear in each variable.
So therefore this is going to equal the covariance of TX with TEACs plus twice
the covariance of t plus the covariance of TX and one minus t y a plus
the covariance of one minus t y and C X,
okay?
Plus one minus t squared.
So I'll put that one over here,
plus one minus t plus the covariance of one minus t y with itself.
Okay?
So I've taken this with this,
then this with that than that with that and that with the thing on the end,
okay?
But it's linear again,
so I can pull out all these things.
So okay,
so,
so that's the formula.
Now what we noticed is that if two stocks,
x and y are independent,
they're covariances zero days.
I'm assuming you remember that.
So those terms just go away.
And then it's also linear.
So this is just going to equal t squared covariance of x with x,
which is the variance of x.
Okay,
so soon x,
y independent.
Then you can see then that is what allows me to cancel these two terms like
that.
So I get t squared times the covariance of x plus one,
one minus t squared,
times the variance variance and variance of y.
If I take t equals a half say,
so if I take two equals ha a half,
okay,
I know that the variance,
the variance of a half x plus a half y equals a quarter times the variance of x
plus a quarter times the variance of y.
We derive this three weeks ago.
I'm just repeating it.
So the amazing thing is if x and y have the same expectation and the same
variance,
but are independent of each other,
by splitting your money between two independent things,
you're obviously going to have the same expectation,
but only,
uh,
half the variance.
And that last step is a variance of x equals variance of Y.
Amazingly,
I mean,
it's not so amazing,
I guess if you thought about it,
but if you haven't thought about it,
you've got to equal risks.
Neither one is better than the other.
So why bother with one rather than the other?
They're both the same.
But if they're independent,
you should put half your money in each of them.
You'll get the same expectation,
but you're going to get only half the variance.
So if you have to dice,
let's say,
uh,
the first die we'll give you,
you pay $100 for a dice.
You can get a hundred you can get a hundred plus the number of dots showing.
So if it gets a one that's $101 and get a six,
it's $106.
So if you held one dice one day,
you'd get on average 103 and a half dollars.
You could pay a hundred get a dye,
which on average pay 203 and a half.
Instead you could put $50 in the first die,
get half of that,
$50 in the second die,
get half of that.
So on average,
you're still getting a hundred,
three and a half,
but the variance you get is going to be half of what it was before.
Okay?
So in this picture,
you start off with x and y with the same standard deviation and the same
expectation,
but they're independent and now you put half of your money in each and you all,
you cut the variance in half,
which means you divide,
you know the standard deviation is the square root.
So you divided by the square root of two.
Okay?
So you've improved,
you've moved to the left,
you've gotten less standard deviation without constricting your expectation at
all.
Okay?
So that's the most important thing to notice.
And I'm going to say it one more thing,
one more way.
Okay.
I'm going to say,
I'm going to go back to this formula.
Okay.
Which is where the variance was here.
Now suppose I,
um,
okay,
so suppose what's,
look at that formula.
Okay.
Suppose I take two stocks,
uh,
which I'm going to switch now x and y.
That was most unfortunate.
But suppose I take two stocks and I'm,
I'm at the point where all my money is and why.
So I'm going to take the case t equals zero,
okay?
But before I take t,
so if I took t equals zero,
I would just have the variance of y.
Okay?
So this would be,
oh,
that's actually quite good.
The variance of y.
Okay,
so I have all my money and why I'd have this standard deviation and this
expectation.
Now what happens if the two have the same?
Uh,
what if the two are independent x and y?
Let's drop the fact that that they have the same variance.
Now maybe x has way more variance than why does,
okay?
So look at x is much riskier than y.
Maybe x has a higher variation,
that higher expectation than Y,
but it's so risky.
You know,
people who are risk averse wouldn't ever want to subject themselves to all this
risk.
Say,
okay,
so maybe they should just stick with why you would think,
but no,
the answer is you shouldn't.
Because what happens if you start to mix some of your money in why?
And put a little bit,
take it a little out of why and put a little bit into x.
Well,
your cheat,
your expectation.
If you take a little money out of why and put a little into x,
your expectations is going to go up because it's going to be the average of x
and y.
So the expectations going up,
but then you say,
oh,
but my variance is going up so I wouldn't want to do it.
But no,
that's wrong.
The variance is not going up because they're independent.
Even though x has a way higher variance than why mixing a little between the two
lowers your variance.
So how could that be?
Seems quite shocking.
Well,
let's take the derivative of this with respect to having all your money
originally and why.
So this is the variance putting t dollars and acts and one minus t and y.
So we simply take the derivative of that with which I've done here.
I suppose I could just,
Oh,
why don't I just write it out?
Take the dream of that
DDT of this.
Okay equals two t times the variance of x plus two times one minus t times.
Okay?
But this is a minus.
I have to,
you know,
I take the driven,
it's two times this times minus one.
So minus two t two times one wine is teen variance of y.
So let's evaluate that at t equals zero.
The first term is zero.
The T is zero.
So this doesn't matter the second term to you,
zero.
So this is minus two times the variance of y.
It's going down,
okay?
The variance is actually going down here,
So just as the says,
the Varian starts down,
eventually it has to end up here.
So as you move your money,
all of it originally and why and start moving some of it into x,
your variance is going to go down.
Okay?
So that those two things put together are the argument for diversification.
If they're independent and they're,
they're identical,
venue should would half of your money in each.
But even if they're not identical,
you shouldn't stick to why you should mix why with some acts.
Okay?
So there is why diversification is such a good idea.
So it's not all diversification.
It's diversification of independent risks.
So there's a little bit of a mathematical nuance.
Diversification of independent risks is bound to help you.
Everybody should diversify a little bit cause you can reduce your risk.
Okay,
so that's the first important fought.
Yeah,
no I don't want to um,
do too much in the mathematics.
But uh,
so I prove in the t in the notes,
but I won't do it here.
Suppose we didn't assume x and Y we're independent.
Suppose x and y were arbitrarily chosen.
You know,
they have big covariance,
whatever you want.
Okay.
Then what is going to happen when you combine your money between x and y?
So there's a proof,
which I'm not going to give because I'm a little bit behind.
So the proof is this.
Suppose we have exactly the same situation where you started with why and you've
got x and you could think of moving your money in between x and y.
Okay,
well if it turns out,
if they're perfectly correlated,
so really they're the same thing.
Why is just,
you know,
80% of acts,
it's the same stock.
So moving back between them,
it's not really changing your,
your,
you know,
w x is just a bag,
uh,
a scalar improvement on why so it has more expectation and more standard
deviation.
If that were the case,
you just move on that straight line that connects the two points.
I must have a way of doing this.
Yes.
So just if they were perfectly correlated,
you would just be moving along this line by putting your money in between.
If they're independent that you're going to move along that line.
Okay.
But no matter how correlated they are,
as long as they're not perfectly correlated,
it's going to turn out the curve you get by moving between them,
it's going to look like that.
If there are negatively correlated,
then you can really improve yourself and you'll get a curve that looks like that
independent will be like this,
uh,
positive correlated but not perfectly.
It will be like that and a perfectly positively correlated,
no diversification gains.
You get the straight line,
but you're always above the straight line.
Okay.
So that's a kind of,
anyway,
that's a,
okay,
it takes a little bit of a Algebra a to prove that,
you know,
the Koshi Schwartz and equality,
but we're not,
so we skipped that.
But anyway,
that's a mathematical fact.
Okay.
And you see an independent case.
We basically,
uh,
you know,
we proved,
we proved that the line has to start going that way and eventually it has to end
up here.
So it shouldn't be no surprise that it looks like that and the independent case.
And then it turns out that every other cases sort of in between that are at the
other extreme.
And it always has this bowed out shape.
Okay?
So there's always gains to diversification.
Um,
something you're getting out of diversification,
the risk is somehow going down by mixing things up.
All right?
So that's it.
That's the,
that's the mathematics.
And that's the general principle.
Now,
what can you get out of this?
I want to derive these two famous theorems,
which we already saw in action and the example that we calculated,
but it seemed like a miracle.
So what did we find in the example we calculated last time in class,
we found that there we only had two stocks,
but if there had been hundreds of stocks and millions of states of nature and
each person had a different utility,
different risk aversion,
but all quadratic,
and you calculated the competitive equilibrium,
assuming there are arrows securities,
it would end up that every consumer held the same mix of all these stocks plus
positive or negative amounts of a bond.
So the mutual fund theorem turned out to be true that the best thing everybody
could do was hold the same amount,
the same proportion of stocks and bonds,
and maybe more or less of the riskless asset,
maybe even negative of the riskless acid.
So I want to show you why that's true now it seems like,
and then we're going to have to talk about whether they really believe it or
not.
So let's see what an implication is.
Well,
suppose now what I do is I write down,
I have all these stocks,
x,
Y,
and z.
So you could imagine you have a certain amount of money.
Okay.
So you could imagine putting money,
putting your money.
So let's suppose that I've written down all the stocks.
The prices are given,
let's say prices
of stocks or enact Librium.
Okay,
so I saw for the equilibrium like we did last time,
and I write down x,
Q,
y,
and z.
These are the expectation and standard deviation per dollar of uh,
the stocks or per I dollars on the stock.
Maybe the person has exactly I dollars.
So let's say it's I dollars of each stock,
what their expectation in return and standard deviation would be.
If,
if a $1,
you get some expectation,
standard deviation,
$10 for the same stock,
you'd be able to buy 10 shares,
which means you would a 10 times as many shares,
which means you'd have 10 times the expectation and 10 times the standard
deviation.
Okay?
So I can,
you know,
I,
whenever the guy's income is,
I'll fix the dollars any,
they'll fix these returns as per his income because he's going to spend all his
income on these stocks.
Okay?
So what could he do?
He could put all his money into X.
He'd end up here or all his money into why he ended up here are all his money
into z and he's ended up here,
but maybe wants to divide part of his money and why and part of it,
pardon Z and part and why he'll be somewhere like here or maybe wants to instead
put part of his money inZ and part of it in acts while he could,
he could end up here,
but why should he stop there?
Maybe he wants to take some combination of the money that was in z and x,
you know,
and combine it with some combination of things that was in z and lie,
combine this and this,
that will get them out to here.
Okay.
So there are lots of different combinations a he could hold.
So graphically it looks like that mathematically.
Yeah.
Mathematically.
What's he trying to do?
He's trying to,
so are now I've replaced a with our,
so RJ is just going to equal a j um,
divided by the price of Jay.
Maybe Times I,
okay.
So Rj will be the
fact,
let's just say it's pie.
It's a age,
a divided by Pi j.
So Rj is the return per dollar.
You putting the acid,
RJ is the payoff of the acid per dollar.
Let's stick with that.
Let's say the guy's a dollar to spend.
So it's the return per dollar.
Okay?
And so and so those are all as possibilities.
Now what does he want to do?
He wants to choose his money.
How much money he's going to put in each acid.
Okay?
Which is only go one through Omega j.
That's the money he's going to put in each acid.
And if he does that,
he's going to have a portfolio,
which is,
you know,
I'll write as our omega.
So it's going to have a certain expectation,
a certain,
so the question is how should he divide his money between the assets?
Okay?
And here's the kind of stuff he could imagine doing was very complicated,
but it's going to turn out to be very simple.
So there are any questions about what we're doing so far.
So I want to get a simple rule to tell you what the practical advice about what
to do.
So Marco,
it's posed this problem.
This is the mark,
okay?
Now it turns out by this argument,
you see that I,
if I keep combining things over and over again,
I'm getting this sort of blob.
But the blog is always pushing itself further and further out.
It's always convex cause given any two points,
I can always do the thing to the left of it.
So,
so if I could do this and I could do this and I look at the line connecting
them,
I can always be above that line by spreading my money.
Between those two acids are given this combination of acids that produce this
expectation and standard deviation and given that one up there,
I can combine the two and do better than the straight line connecting them due
to the left of it.
So therefore all the combinations put together have to geometrically look like
this in the end.
Okay?
So I'm going to do this algebraically in a second.
They have to look like that if I did every possible variation,
okay?
It couldn't have,
it couldn't end up with a picture where after I do every possible variation.
If this is the expectation,
this is the standard deviation.
I couldn't get something that looked like that because I would just combine this
thing with this thing,
whatever portfolio produced this,
whatever portfolio produced that I put half my money into each of the stocks at.
This told me to do half the money in each of the stocks this told me to do.
I'd still end up investing $1 and instead of getting the line,
I get something that looked like that.
Okay,
so I couldn't have the thing going in like that.
It has to go out,
but then of course I can combine this and this and get that and so I'm going to
end up with this kind of shape.
Now I'm going to prove that algebraically,
but if I had that kind of shape,
then what would the guy do?
He'd choose something like that where he's tangent.
Okay.
That's what Mark Woods basically did,
except he did it algebraically.
So let's,
okay.
All right,
so that's what Mark Woods did.
Okay.
All right,
so that doesn't seem to have gotten us very far.
So you notice that different people are going to make different choices.
If somebody care is incredibly worried about,
um,
someone's not very worried about the standard deviation and cares a lot about
expectation,
they're going to have a flatter indifference curve.
So instead of looking like that,
it'll be a flatter thing.
And so if it's flatter,
the guy who cares,
this is the guy,
sorry if it's flat or it means he cares about expectation and not standard
deviation because you know a little bit of expectation can compensate him for a
lot more standard deviation.
So it was indifference curve flatter.
He's going to choose further up and so he's going to choose a point like way up
there and so he's going to get a higher expectation and higher standard
deviation and someone who's more risk averse is going to choose like where that
point is.
So that's qualitative.
We what's going on?
All right,
so Mark Woods played around with his,
played around with this,
then Tobin appears on the scene and Tobin says all this gets so much easier if
you have a riskless acid.
Let's suppose that there's a bond.
You haven't mentioned the bond yet.
Let's suppose we have a bond.
Okay,
that pay something for sure.
And we're going to ignore inflation.
Tobin said,
which is a big problem because we have,
we should come back to that if we have time.
We're going to ignore inflation.
So us treasuries going to pay a certain amount of money for sure.
So it has an expectation like this,
but no standard deviation is zero.
Now,
why is this so important?
Well,
let's imagine combining this riskless bond with some other stock x,
a dollar's worth of x dollars worth of the riskless bond gets you 1.06 say a
dollar's worth of x gets you much.
You know,
maybe your average is one point 12 but your,
you're also running a big risk.
What happens if you put your money part way in between them?
Okay?
Okay.
So suppose you put part of your money in acts and the rest of your money in the
riskless bond.
What's your expectation going to be where your expectation,
let's say you know axes 12% and why is 6% 1.06 and 1.12 okay,
the average is going to be 1.09 if you put half your money in both,
but what is the standard deviation going to be?
Okay,
well I claim it's just going to be on that straight line.
Why is that?
Because the risk list thing has covariate zero if x is riskless,
it's covariants is going to be zero with why.
So these terms are going to disappear.
Okay,
look at the covariants.
If,
if x,
if Jay is the riskless bond,
it pays always its expectations.
So these numbers are always zero.
So therefore the covariance of that thing with anything go variance of y with
any ax is going to be zero.
So therefore,
and not only that,
but the variance of y itself is also zero.
So all you get is for the,
for the variance of a t dollars and acts and one minus t dollars.
And why you just get t squared times the variance of x.
But then when you take the standard deviation,
it's just t times the standard deviation of y,
of x.
So in other words,
the variant,
the standard deviation of the mixture of why annex lives right on the line.
So unlike to put another way,
something that has no variances perfectly correlated with everything else,
it makes no difference whether other thing goes up or down.
It doesn't tell you,
you still know it,
why he's going to be so,
okay.
So unlike everything else where you have this bowl shape thing,
the riskless asset just connects everything to a straight line.
So if there were a riskless acid and you can do this with some x and here was
the z,
you could also do that.
Or You could do that.
Is this clear?
Okay.
So the punchline,
which we're now gonna see Algebraic Lee,
the punch line is,
and by the way,
if I combine,
what does it mean to extend that wine?
I should have extended that line.
That was a huge mistake.
Suppose instead of,
so here I put half,
here's all the money in the riskless acid,
here's half the wanting the risk of this asset and half an x.
Here's all my money in x.
What would happen if I extended the line here?
What would that correspond to?
I'm now at a point on the extension of the wine.
What does that,
how do I get that?
Yeah,
right.
That's negative y and and bigger than one in x.
So negative a half of x plus one and a half of why that's still a dollar.
I sold x short and so I'm just going to continue the line that way.
Okay,
so I shouldn't have stopped here.
I could've kept going.
Okay,
so it's,
it's putting money in the bank and sharing it between a single stock puts me on
this line,
borrowing money from the bank to put in the stock.
It's called leveraging my return puts me on the extension of the line.
We're going to come back to that in a second.
Okay,
so knowing that now,
what should I do?
Is there something really simple?
Well,
what would you do here faced with this choice?
I mean which combination of stocks and bonds would you hold?
I say it's really simple.
You just look for a line through the risk list point that's tangent to this
blurb,
chaplains to be here
and now you should choose your point anywhere along this line.
Independent of what your utilities,
your mean variance,
utilities are,
no matter how risk averse you are or how risk loving you are,
you should choose somewhere along this line.
Hey,
why?
Why is that?
Well,
I've drawn with this Blob,
I've drawn all the possible combinations I could get by mixing different risky
assets when I left out of the picture is all the combinations I could get by
adding the,
the riskless asset.
I've got all the risky acid combination.
So that's the blob.
Okay.
And now I want to do the adding the riskless acid means I can take,
you know,
part of my money in here,
in part in there.
So in particular I can put part of my money here and part of my money there or I
can go short.
So whatever this combination was,
that's the best thing I should,
I can do now I can get everything along this line.
Nothing else can do better because let's,
what other combination could there be?
It has to be the risk,
less acid plus a bunch of risky assets,
but combining the risky assets just puts me in the blob.
Okay.
And then combining whatever.
So it,
Mike put me here in the blob and the ones I combine that with the riskless acid,
I'll be on that line.
This line is always below that line.
So this is the best possible thing I can do.
No combination of the restless acid and any other combination of risky acids
that always put me on some line from here through some point in the blog,
which is going to belong be below this tangent point.
So this is the best thing I can do and it's independent of whether I was risk
averse or risk lover.
If I'm risk averse and want to play it safe,
you know my utility function,
I forgot what those looked like.
My indifference curves,
you know,
I'll,
I'll do,
I'll be here.
I'll put most of my money in the bank and not very many and the risky stock.
If I'm more of a risk lover,
I'll be me,
be here and I'll choose to put a good fraction of my money in the stock and only
a little in the bank.
If I'm really reckless,
I'll borrow money and putting the stock market and be way up there.
Okay.
So,
but everybody will do the same thing no matter what their preferences are.
They'll all be along the same line.
Okay,
so that's the mutual fund theorem.
Why is that?
The Mutual Fund Theorem?
Because it says everybody shouldn't invest in the same index of stocks and put
more or less money in the bank.
So every single person ought to be doing the same thing.
This is the mutual fund that everybody should hold.
Whatever combination of stocks that got me to this point is the,
is the mutual fund that everybody should hold and combine that with putting
money in the bank.
Okay.
So let's just prove that algebraically in a special case,
which is going to illustrate the point,
the idea of it anyway.
Okay.
So I'm doing a very special case here,
but just to illustrate it algebraically.
So suppose that the rs are,
as we said,
the returns up here per dollar of stock,
the okay,
the the R Zero I've now added,
and that's going to be the riskless asset that pays like a dollar six all the
time.
If the interest rate is 6% so now you have your money.
Oh my God,
I dollars.
You're the investor with I dollars.
You can divide that money into the riskless acid or any one of the J uh,
assets.
So here you've got r zero you can get that return our won up to Rj and you can
put money,
Omega Zero Omega One Omega j.
But of course this all has to add up to I.
So how should you do it?
Well,
you care about your expectation and you hate variance.
So I'm doing just a special case to make it a illustrate the idea.
Suppose I write down your utility as if it were the expectation minus Alpha
Times the variance.
It could be a more complicated function.
You know,
we said already that the quadratic utility is giving you expectation minus some
Alpha expectation squared minus some other Alpha Times.
The variance,
right?
That's the utility we derived from quadratic.
When people have quadratic utility is over consumption,
they're induced utility of our portfolios.
Is this thing.
Okay,
so it's not exactly the one I've written down,
but the argument would be just the same.
And this is shorter and simpler.
So just to illustrate the flavor of it,
let's say all you care about is your expectation minus some constant,
how risk averse you are at times the variance.
And now let's suppose to keep it even simpler that the assets are all
independent.
Okay.
None of the theory doesn't rely on that.
I'm just saying suppose it worse so he can algebraically get it without having
to work very hard.
So you're maximizing your expectation.
So the bar above means the expectation.
So what's your expectation of Omega dollars in here?
Omega one in here and Omega Jay in here.
Just Omega zero times the expectation of this.
So your expectation then it's going to be only cause zero times are zero bar.
That's the expectation of that.
Plus Omegle on our bar,
one plus Omega j r Bar j,
that's your,
these are at the top for some reason.
That's your expectation.
Now what's your variance?
The thing that you don't like,
your variance is going to be,
well,
the variance is just going to be the variance of these,
their independence.
So the variance is just going to be,
um,
what I've written.
Okay.
Omega,
whatever the V.
So I'll call the variance of RJ sigma.
So it's going to be single is zero squared.
That's the variance of Sigma Cro Times Omega Zero squared.
Remember,
because for varying,
you have to square feet,
multiply by something,
okay?
Plus only go one squared sigma,
one squared,
plus all my good j squared,
Sigma j squared.
Now of course,
remember that the variance,
the riskless thing is zero.
So that's actually zero.
Okay?
So this is the variance you have to watch out for.
This is the expectation you want.
How should you pick Omega Zero Omega,
Omega,
Che,
um,
when your penalty for,
for having too much variances.
Alpha.
Okay.
So different investors have different risk aversion.
So they have different Alphas.
Should they be led as Mark Woods thought without the riskless asset.
Remember with the Blob,
like this one guy who's going to pick here,
another guy was going to pick there,
they'd all do very different things.
Tobin added this riskless acid and low and behold,
now everyone should do the same.
So why is that?
We just produced this algebraically.
Okay,
solve it algebraically.
So the constraint is a nuisance to maximize something with the constraints.
A nuisance.
So you just noticed that if you satisfy the constraint,
Omega zero has to equal I minus the sum of the Omega Jays.
So if I substitute for Omega Zero Right up there,
I substitute I minus the sum of the Jays,
then I'm going to get
our bar zero times I minus our bar zero times Omega one minus r Bar Zero Times
only get to so,
but I can feed that into the other thing.
So I get um,
our zero times the eye.
And then the r one in term is going to be our bar one times omega one minus the
thing that came from subtracting the Omega one there in I minus Omega is by
replacing Omega zero with high minus,
uh,
when we go one minus Oma,
good Jay,
etc.
So I'm going to notice all these other terms.
Now I get rid of the constraint and all the other terms get replaced.
Our bar to gets replaced by Arab are two minus our zero.
Okay.
And so,
and I've dropped sigma zero because it's zero.
So I'm maximizing something without a constraint by plugging in the constraint
and to Omega Zero.
Okay?
So I have to choose my only go one through only good Jay.
Um,
and then Omega zero is determined from that,
but I'm maximizing one thing.
So I just take the derivative with respect to each Omega I and set it equal to
zero.
So with respect to Omega one,
say it's going to be our one bar,
one minus r bars,
zero minus two Alpha Sigma to differentiate with respect to Omega one.
So it's two Alpha Omega one time sigma one squared to Alpha Omega one time sigma
one squared equals zero.
Okay,
so therefore Omega one equals r one minus r zero over to Alpha Sigma one
squared.
But if I did it now with respect to two or to three or to four nothing,
I would get the same formula just with Ajay instead of a one.
Okay,
so that's the formula everybody picks and notice it depends on what Alpha is.
So people with different Alphas,
they're going to put different amounts of money and oh my God,
Jay,
okay.
But it depends on Alpha and a very trivial way.
So if I took the,
the fraction,
the relative amounts of money,
I put an I in j and divided this by Omega I by Omega Jay,
I would get that the Alphas and the twos canceled out.
So everybody would put our I minus our bar zero divided by Sigma I squared r Bar
j minus Arzeo over sigma squared.
Jay,
that number doesn't depend on who the person is.
So the relative amounts of money and put an I and j are independent of what your
Alpha is independent of the person.
So unlike this old Markowitz case,
the Tobin case looks like that and everybody chooses the combination of risky
assets and then Russ safe acid.
So maybe the different people put different combinations of safe and risky,
but everybody's proportion of risky assets is proportional to everybody else's.
That's what we just proved algebraically.
So graphically and Algebraically,
graphically,
a sort of general proof algebraically,
a special case.
And then if you were in a graduate class,
you'd get an algebraic proof in general,
which is actually much faster than these were the east,
but you'd have to know a little less linear Algebra.
And so that's the proof.
It's a very simple thing.
Okay.
It's a remarkable thing.
And here's the famous Tobin diagram.
Everybody should do that,
put their money in the same combination of risky assets and the riskless acid.
Okay.
Are there any questions about this?
It's kind of shocking.
You know,
I could swear that,
uh,
most people think maybe even rightly that,
you know,
if you really want to go for it,
put your money in the young Microsoft or something.
Um,
you know,
it could be a tremendous success or it could go out of business.
That's what she should do.
But no,
this says not at all.
If you really want to go for it,
take the same index that everybody,
the s and p 500 and just leverage it,
borrow a lot of money and go out that straight line way out to there to the
right.
Don't put your money in Microsoft.
Just leverage the hell out of the s and p 500.
Yeah.
Okay.
So after this theory was created and we're going to talk,
I'm gonna,
you know,
tease out all the implications of it.
After this theory was created,
the Mutual Fund business took off vanguard and all these places.
What did they do?
They said,
look,
economic science has taught us the best you can do is not try to pick individual
stocks.
The best you can do is to hold the same index,
the whole market.
Now of course it's very expensive for you to hold the whole market or you're
going to go to a broker and tell him,
buy me three shares of this and seven shares of that at nine shares of that,
14 shares of that.
It'll take the guy forever to buy all that stuff.
And you have to pay a commission on every single single thing you buy.
It's going to cost you so much money to do what economic science says.
Come to us at vanguard.
We'll buy the whole market for you.
Call it our index fund and charge you almost no commission at all.
Just a tiny little bit.
And you know,
cause we're doing it in such bulk,
everyone's going,
you know,
cause we've got lots of investors like you.
They're all buying the same thing.
We have huge volumes.
So we're going to get a really a small brokerage fee.
And so,
uh,
you should put your money in with us.
So that's what everybody started to do.
So all these mutual funds and money managers,
they all grew up originally by guaranteeing to produce an index fund.
The very same thing,
economic science recommended at almost no cost.
If you read Swenson,
spork and you,
and he said,
you know,
his first most important piece of advice,
if you're a standard investor who doesn't know how to,
you know,
manipulate all complicated instruments on Wall Street and has transactions costs
and things like that,
put all your money into an index.
That's what he recommends doing.
And he says,
everyone else who tells you otherwise is just trying to steal your money,
rip you off.
So that's the main financial advice that um,
economists give.
Now it's Shakespeare's advice,
okay,
don't put all your eggs in one basket,
but it's very specific.
Put it in an index.
Where will you buy everything,
uh,
in the same proportion?
Now of course,
if you're buying everything in the same proportion and everybody's doing that,
what does this have to be?
So I forgot to say that if everybody's buying every stock in the same
proportion,
that proportion must be the market because that's what everybody's holding.
So this doesn't turn out to be any old portfolio.
It's the market portfolio.
So the index,
that's a huge conclusion here,
that the index that they should offer is not just some magical index that's
better than everything else.
Because if everyone is doing the right thing,
everyone's choosing the right in the same index.
That's what we proved.
If everyone's choosing the same index,
it must be the market index because that's all there is to choose suppliers to
equal demand.
So therefore the,
the,
the advice is to put all your money into the market index,
not just unindexed the market index plus maybe put money in a bank or even
borrow from a bank to put it into the market index.
That's the first,
uh,
surprising ferrum that Tobin approved.
And it had dramatic,
a dramatic.
So we created the,
you know,
indexed investments,
a created vanguard.
And so these people who run these companies forgot the guy's name,
who runs vanguard.
He's always giving these speeches.
Um,
so that's how he describes how he got his start in his business.
All he says is I take all the recommendations of economic science.
He says,
and I allow people to carry them out.
That's why I'm doing great.
Good for society or everybody else.
All these hedge funds and stuff,
they're ruining society.
I am just doing what Tobin told us to do that.
That's his basic speech.
Um,
okay.
So Markowitz was a little bit more precise even than that.
The woods formula and Tobin special case,
he not only told you what to do,
he told you,
you know,
do what everyone else is doing,
but he told you what that should be.
Okay.
So let's suppose that I've got two stocks,
I and J with the same,
um,
same return,
same expected return,
but one has a standard deviation,
three times higher than the other.
Okay?
So in my picture here,
that standard picture,
we've got the standard deviation.
We've got the expectation,
we've got one stock here,
and we've got another stock here with three times the standard deviation.
Okay?
So you might've thought,
well,
these stocks,
same expected return.
What's the difference?
Put all my money in one or the other.
Doesn't matter.
I'm a little bit further thought.
Would say,
well,
this one is much better than that one.
I,
you know,
I've got smaller standard deviation,
so I should put all my money into this one.
But then on further thought,
given that these two are independent,
so they're independent,
what should you do?
How should you allocate your money between this stock and that stock?
What is the formula tells you to do?
Very clear.
Okay,
well this is the
ratio of money in one stock to the other stock looks like this ratio,
but I've told you that the expectations and the two stocks are the same.
So those things are the same and I've totally,
that one has three times the standard deviation than the other.
So therefore,
what should you do?
Yup,
exactly.
You shouldn't hold put 90% in this stock,
10% of that stock.
That's it.
Okay.
Because if one sigma three times the other and you squared,
it's going to be nine times the other.
And so obviously you're putting it,
you know,
and then you have to figure out what's in the numerator and what's in the
denominator.
But clearly you're going to put more of your money in the lower standard
deviation.
So it's 90 10 okay.
So it's very concrete advice.
Okay.
So the first concrete advice is first concrete thing we've gotten out of this is
by the index.
Okay?
Now the index,
typically in America there,
they're easy to buy our indexes of stocks.
But you know,
the second piece of advices,
and,
and this is also Swenson.
Second most important point.
I mean,
I'm quoting Swenson because we're here at Yale,
not because he's the only one to recognize these things,
but he was a student of Tobin.
So the second important point is that,
um,
you should not just buy the index because the index is,
or the wrong index.
The index should be the index of everything.
It should include American stocks,
Chinese stocks,
French stocks,
weak stocks,
Israeli stocks.
You should have all stocks in the index,
but you can't really very easily by all those other things.
You can only very easily by index of American things.
It's getting easier and easier now to buy into,
you know,
the global index.
But anyway,
you shouldn't buy the global index.
That's what this says.
Okay?
So every time you find a new independent risk,
you should look for it.
So you should buy the global index,
seek out independent risks.
So what did Swensen do?
One of his most important things was Yale is always looking globally to find
independent risks.
So let's go back to the uh,
okay.
So you should always find independent risks.
Okay?
And you suffer if you don't.
So you see by putting 90% here and 10% here,
Marcos is telling you you're going to do better.
So,
all right,
what else do I have to say?
Um,
okay.
So let's try and go back to our dice example.
Suppose that you had a one dice.
Now,
by the way,
I want to introduce one more term.
Okay?
So which I'll call the Sharpe ratio.
So the slope of this line,
so it's the Tobin diagram.
It shouldn't be called the Tobin ratio.
What's this other guy had?
Stanford's snuck in and managed to give his name to it and he ended up getting a
Nobel prize too.
Um,
so he,
so here,
this,
this line,
the slope of this line,
this is the riskless asset.
Okay?
The slope of this line.
What is the slope of this line?
So this is standard deviation.
This is expectation and the slope,
what's the slope?
Well,
it's the expectation of whatever you're holding.
X minus the riskless asset.
Yeah.
Okay.
Divided by the standard deviation of x,
that's the Sharpe ratio of X.
Okay?
So you noticed that every point you could,
could conceivably choose which is somewhere in this blob then connected to the
riskless asset.
So every point on this line obviously has the same sharp ratio.
If you leverage your position and went to here,
you wouldn't change your Sharpe ratio.
It says the same slope.
Okay?
If you put half of your money in the bank and half and the rest of the SAS,
it'd be here saying Sharpe ratio.
Anything else you could do has a lower Sharpe race show.
So another thing to say is that,
uh,
an investor,
okay.
Managing all his money.
Okay.
Should match,
should maximize this sharp ratio.
Max Sharpe ratio.
Okay.
So you could in fact tell if somebody had screwed up.
Instead of doubling doing the global index,
they just did the American index.
You don't pick something here.
You could look at the slope of where they ended up and it would be a worse slope
in a worst Sharpe ratio.
So you can even judge people how they're doing by looking at their Sharpe ratio.
So let's take the case of the two dice.
Okay.
Suppose you had one die.
So if you had one die,
remember,
invest $100 you could get 101 hundred two or three 106 let's say the interest
rate is 3% so,
um,
so you could get 100100200 300400500 six with the sixth probability a sixth
each.
Okay?
So the average of that is obviously 103.5,
right?
Because one in six or seven and divide by two,
the oil 3.5.
So the expected payoff for putting your,
your money into one dice is the average return is 1.035.
The riskless return is going to be 1.03 so,
so it's 0.035 minus 0.0 3.05 and now what's the standard deviation?
What's the variance of this where you could take one oh one minus one oh three
five squared plus one or two minus one or three five squared,
et cetera.
And take the square root of it and you'd get 0.017 okay,
so you notice the chance of losing money by the way is 50% 50% of the time
you're going to lose money and your sharp ratio is 0.05 or 0.017 so that's about
3.3 it's about 0.3 now that happens to be the sharp ratio of the stock market
just about shockingly low,
isn't it?
If you look at the history of the stock market,
so it depends what year you start and what year you end.
You know if you do it right after a crash or before a crash.
But just to pick vague numbers,
it's like 9% and let's say the interest rate is you know,
4% something like that.
You know,
it could be 5% or 3% depends again the period.
Okay,
maybe it's 2%.
Okay.
But somewhere like that.
And the standard deviation of the stock market is,
you know,
like 16% or 12% you know,
again,
depending on what period,
but always around 12 to 18% let's say 16% that's the one I like to use because
it's percent a day of a,
okay,
so that,
um,
that's equal to 5% over 16%,
which is about a third.
Hey,
lets you know it's about 0.3.
That's exactly what this dice had about 0.3.
So that's all you can get out of the stock market.
Not a very good sharp ratio.
So you could measure,
you know,
Swenson Sharpe ratio.
You could measure Ellington Sharpe ratio and see what they are.
You can see who you think is a better manager.
Okay.
So now,
um,
uh,
so I won't tell you those numbers just yet,
but now let's suppose you,
um,
what else could I do?
Okay,
so let's suppose you put your money in two dice.
That's the whole point of this.
Suppose you put half your money in the first dice and half your money in the
second tie.
Okay?
Now,
what are the chances?
What's going to happen?
Well,
again,
your,
your expected return hasn't changed.
It's still 0.035,
but the sharp ratio has drastically changed.
In fact,
you could see that what are the chances of ending up with $101?
Now,
if you put half of your money in each,
the worst case,
it's not one in six.
You have to get the worst case in both dies.
So to get $101,
it's one in 36.
Okay.
It's vastly less likely that you end up with this extreme bad outcome once you
put half the money in each die.
So if you compute the standard deviation is going to be a lot smaller number.
Okay?
It's going to be 0.01 uh,
I,
it's going to be 0.012 so the Sharpe ratio has gone from 0.3 to 0.4.
Okay.
Just by finding the second die.
So what you should be doing is looking like Swinson does,
like everybody does for those independent risks that the rest of the market is
too stupid to see.
Even after they got the idea of the index for 20 years,
they didn't realize the index should mean everything,
not just in America.
So you'd have a huge opportunity to do better than the rest of the managers.
You know,
while everybody else is screwing around on this line,
you can be screwing around on that wine so you could run the same risk this guy
did.
Okay?
So if you're Swinson say you could leverage,
not that he does,
but if you're a Harvard and you're on this thing instead of this thing,
you could leverage and go up a here and you can say,
look,
I've got the same standard deviation everybody else does.
And look at my returns.
There's so much higher than everybody else's.
Okay.
So that's what Harvard is trying to do.
They're trying to globally diversify,
cut down their standard deviation,
and then leverage and compare it to everybody else.
Get a higher return with the same standard deviation.
Okay?
So that's the first implication of the theory.
Now the second application is the best part.
Let's hope I get to it.
Um,
okay,
so I'm going to skip over leverage.
So the second and the second story is a coming right up.
Okay.
How are these things priced?
Hope this.
Okay,
so I have to get to the second part of Shakespeare.
Okay.
What can we say about the pricing of individual stocks?
Now it looks like an individual stock is going to be worth more if it
contributes.
No variance,
less variance.
But that turns out to be completely wrong and it's shocking that that's wrong.
Okay,
so why is this?
Well,
the crucial thing is,
remember back to our first principles.
What is price equal to?
What's the key ingredient to price?
What does it always equal?
Two and basic economics.
Supply and demand.
Okay.
But if an individual is going to buy so that price is equal to his marginal
utility,
right?
So we have to figure out,
so what we've shown so far is that everybody is holding the market.
Everybody's uh,
right.
Holding a market maybe with some riskless acid.
Okay?
So they're holding the market.
Plus maybe there are long or short the bonds,
but that's not creating any covariance.
So if I ask,
if I'm holding the market and I hold a little bit more of a stock,
okay,
so I,
if I could pay a little bit more and by t units of stock x,
what good would it do me?
Well,
the expectation,
the change in expectation with ti dollars of x would be is I increased t a
little bit.
The derivative.
Why expectations?
Just the expectation of X.
Okay.
So by holding the new stock,
I get expectation of,
I get a little more,
I get t times the expectation of x by hope putting,
if I came up with t extra dollars,
I could increase my expectation by t times the expectation of acts obviously.
But what would happen to my variance?
Well look at the variance of this.
What happens to my variance?
Okay.
Which is equal Bavarians I could write as the covariance of this with itself.
T x plus M.
Okay,
so I'm taking,
right,
I want to see,
everybody's supposed to hold em plus some risk was thing negative or positive in
the bond.
Okay.
Or,
but
the negative or positive and the bond is riskless asset that contributes nothing
to the covariance.
So I might as well just look at the covariance of a little bit of money in acts
with the market.
And what's that covariance going to be?
Well,
it's covariance of t,
TX and Tx,
covariance of TX and,
and uh,
m
hey,
these are definitely not zero anymore.
Okay.
Plus covariance of,
uh,
of,
um,
so it's too
two t covariance of TX and m and then it's the,
uh,
plus covariance of m with itself.
Okay.
So it's the covariance of TX with itself,
TX with TX twice the coal branch of TX with m and the miss TX x with them to
covariance TX with them.
And the covariance of am with itself.
And I want to differentiate that thing with respect to t.
If I put just a little bit of money that's being on the margin,
what's the marginal effect on my variance?
Right?
I hate variance.
But see the mistake people have made in the past is they said people hate
variants,
therefore a stock that has a lot of variances,
bad,
absolutely wrong reasoning.
That was Adam Smith's puzzle about water and diamonds.
You know,
why is water or less expensive than diamonds when water is so much more
important?
It's not how important the whole thing is,
is how important one tiny job of it is the margin utility.
So if you had a tiny bit of x to what you're already holding,
which might involve a bunch of ex already,
she had a tiny bit more of to what all you're already holding,
what's going to be the change in your variants?
So it's the derivative of this with respect to t when t equals zero.
Okay?
So this by the way,
equals t squared variance of x plus two covariance to t
times the covariance of x and m plus the variance of m.
Okay?
And I'm differentiating this with respect to t
but if I different,
right cause that's what I've just rewritten the same thing.
That's this as t squared,
the variance of x,
the tea comes out to tea covariance of x with them and here's the variance of m.
But if I differentiate with respect to t,
I get to t variance of X.
Remember it's the derivative when t is zero.
Hey two t variance of x plus two covariance
of x and m plus zero because the variance of m doesn't depend on t.
So at t equals zero.
This is also zero.
So you see the change in my variance when I add a little more of x is twice the
covariance of x and m.
So what is it that acts adds?
It adds some expectation and it also adds some variance but not according to the
variance of x according to the covariance of x.
With him,
when I add some more,
the price of water is how much extra utility I get given what I've already got,
I've already got a huge amount of water.
That's why an extra amount of water is not doing much for me.
That's why the price is low.
So x itself might be very dangerous,
but if it's independent of all the other stuff,
em,
that you're holding,
in fact you're only adding a drop of it.
It won't change your variants hardly at all.
In fact,
it will make it,
you know,
and so it's uh,
this is zero.
Okay?
So it's the covariants.
All right?
So that's the crucial idea that the marginal contribution of every stock depends
on its expectation and it's covariants not its variants.
And the expectation is good and the covariance is bad.
And all of this is linear because it's differentiable.
So it just says that,
you know,
this is the change and covariance.
So you know,
remember the guy,
the margin utility of expectation.
So the margin you,
how am I doing in time?
Okay,
one more minute.
Margie.
Chili of expectation times the expectation of X.
That's the change.
When you add a dollars,
we're a tiny bit of ax.
Your expectation goes up by the expectation of x.
So this is the margin utility of expectation,
which is the good thing,
minus the margin utility of variant variance.
That's the bad thing.
And what's the change?
The thing that affects the,
uh,
the thing that affects the contribution to variance is the covariance of x with
them.
Okay.
The punchline is air me buddy has a linear tradeoff between expectation and
covariance.
Okay?
So for any fixed person,
it's just a US constant times the expectation of x minus a constant times.
This doesn't depend on the portfolio.
This is the large utility at his consumption.
Margie,
utility of expectation at his consumption.
You,
you face him with any possible new thing that he could buy just like a consumer.
And the first day of class,
he could buy apples,
you could buy oranges,
you could buy pairs.
The Mars utility of each one of those at the point he's already chosen to
consume.
This is a number that's fixed.
This is a number of them fixed whatever x I put in here,
that's what I get.
So there's a linear tradeoff between expectation and covariance.
Expectation.
Good.
Covariance bad.
So the final picture is that INAC,
Librium,
what you should have is every stock,
and this is called the security market line.
This is the expectation of x.
This is the covariance of x with Em.
So what we found is that it should look like this and there has to be a linear
relationship in order to want a stock.
If it's got a higher covariance,
that means it's adding bad stuff.
You wouldn't want it unless it had a higher expectation.
Okay?
So here's the risk was here's the riskless asset right here.
So this is a different diagram then the Tobin diary on his expectation and
covariance.
Every stock is along this line,
okay?
Should be priced along this line.
So let me,
um,
uh,
and with a puzzle,
the one we started with on the first day of class,
if I have two companies,
General Motors and AIDS,
I anti AIDS company,
some scientists at Yale discovers a cure for aids.
He calls an aids.
Okay,
here's this cover is a cure for aids.
If the thing works,
he'll make a fortune.
If the thing doesn't work,
of course it's going to go bankrupt.
And pay anyone no money.
Let's say we calculate the expected profits of General Electric,
not jump.
General orders is to junkie now General Electric and let's say the expected
profits of general electric equal the expected profits of the anti AIDS company,
which will sell for a higher price.
Yeah,
we'll sell for a higher price.
Why?
Very good.
Okay.
That's what you should have said at the beginning of class,
but not at the end of class.
Who's saying that?
That's,
you're down here.
Who said that?
Who's your just who just said that I,
I don't wanna embarrass anyone by right.
You're anonymous.
I didn't see how it was.
So that's exactly,
that's what you would've thought before this class began.
Everybody hates variance.
The AIDS company is so risky.
It's,
you know,
you could get a fortune or zero,
you couldn't get riskier than that.
General Electric is not going to go bankrupt very easily and it's not gonna,
you know,
suddenly multiply value by a hundred times either.
It's much more solid.
So,
which would you pay more for?
Everyone at the beginning of the class,
I think would have said like he did well,
whoever he is would've said General Electric you'd pay more for,
but the answer is not General Electric.
Why is that?
Yes.
Okay.
Exactly.
That's the shocking fact.
That's the shocking conclusion that so Shakespeare,
yes.
Nothing ventured,
nothing gained.
You have to take a risk to expect a higher return.
Everyone would've thought it's the,
everyone would have thought that's the AIDS company.
Anti-Aids Company.
No it's not.
And Shakespeare couldn't possibly have figured this out.
It's general electric is the one with the higher risk because it's correlated
with the market.
Okay.
It's correlated with the market.
Obviously if people are richer,
they're gonna buy more refrigerators and engines and stuff like that.
If people,
you know,
businesses and doing very well,
they're not going to buy that stuff.
It's very correlated with the market.
Anti-Aids you know,
if a cure is aids,
people are going to buy it.
If they've got aids,
they're going to buy it no matter what their,
you know,
and the,
otherwise they won't.
So it's uncorrelated with the market.
So therefore the price of the AIDS company is going to be,
it's expected payoff discounted.
The price of General Motors is going to be much less because it's going to be
punished for having a correlation with the market.
Therefore,
the return on General Electric is going to be much higher because the same
expected payoff and a lower price.
It's going to you,
your return's going to be higher in general electric.
That's the shocking thing that Shakespeare couldn't have noticed.
So yes,
we're just doing what Shakespeare said from the beginning,
but in a way he couldn't possibly have done without any mathematics.
Uh,
okay,
so now the problem set,
I,
you'll have to see if he can do the problem set.
It's due on Tuesday.